this is weird and don't answer this
question if you don't want to matter but
i have i don't know why you brought this
up but i did hear you discuss
you had an extraordinary disagreement uh
with your wife
about yourself do you know what i'm
talking about by myself you mean yes
yeah ooh
listen do you know this story listen
with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff
i
and of course being circumcised i said
they were chatting they're married
they're married they're allowed
and she said
she said
you're not circumcised
i said what do you mean you've only
known me a few
all my life i remember my mother telling
me why because it was fashionable at the
time she said you're not circumcised i
said that's ridiculous i should know if
i'm circumcised
of course i am end of conversation but
the next day i happen to be seeing my
doctor
are you okay
i was seeing my doctor for my annual
physical of course so uh
while he was down there
i said excuse me oh by the way
erv um
my wife and i have a little disagreement
um
i i am circumcised aren't i because she
says i'm not
and he goes
not
[Applause]
it's not possible so he looked down
again and he said hey i'm jewish i know
the difference
that is a bizarre
i have grandchildren
you're gonna have to change your
facebook status
no more beef stew
well there's more beef stew
uh phoebe you
i'd say you learned a valuable lesson uh
was it was it hay fever no cartage oh my
god i have had so many regrets about
telling you guys about this
story okay
occasionally
behind backstage there are some japes
with actors you know
sure sure you know you know yeah but
keep the other actors kind of um
entertained when it's a really long run
and i'm really sorry mum that i'm
telling this story um and there was one
i was doing hay fever and it was a three
month run and uh there was one moment
there's one moment on the stage where i
was off stage with this other actor sam
and one of the other actors played by
one of the characters played by freddie
fox would storm across the stage open
this door and we'd be standing behind
the door you know master from the
audience and he had to go
and then he'd slam the door and run back
onto the stage and so we always used to
do something kind of quirky behind the
door to make him laugh
and every night and we started off by
doing a little like oh like we're
kissing or like oh we put a funny hat on
sam but it was three months long this
run and we have to up the game every
night
every single night and so we started
getting the stage management involved
and there were massive like hot dog
costumes and like these before people
from outside to come in so every time
freddie would open the door he'd be like
really excited and he'd be like
and then he was like then we had to
change really quickly and then run on
the stage and the other cast members
could see it and it was building a
building and we were running out of
ideas and it was like a week left and we
were exhausting ourselves and then
suddenly it was getting to the last
night we were like we have to have a big
finish like what are we going to do for
freddie and neither of us could think of
anything and suddenly we did the matinee
and we'd done this kind of wild kind of
like spangly glittery thing and then on
the final performance we had nothing and
we were like we have to do something we
have to do something we could hear
freddie coming across the stage and we
were like we haven't thought of anything
sam just said just
just
i know i've got it just show them your
[__]
oh my gosh that's awful he was like it's
brilliant the stage management around me
going perfect your actually
do that and i was like really and
they're like turning me around i was
like is this gonna be good
i have this huge pink skirt on no it's a
horrendous story i love this huge big
skirt and everyone's like it's gonna be
great and i was like yes it's gonna be
oh my god we're sorry and i was leaning
down and then freddie was running
and i was like bent over with the stage
management like
i think he opened the door and then he
just went
oh
i'm already standing there like oh god
everything's gone quiet and then i
turned around and i saw like the
glitterati of the london stage like
olivia coleman lindsey duncan kevin
mccally all going
yeah too far
well the twelve are bravely told it's
gone now it's gone it's god
things happen to you like you're is it
your house in near dover
oh yes yes
i'm glad you brought that up because i
do rent my house
if you're interested two other people i
mean
and it's the nearest house to france
which is very important in this story
and it's 425 pounds a week and it sleeps
it sleeps um six people so
for seven nights
yes yes anyway
one one day i got a call from the police
and they said um are you the owner of
the gun emplacement and i said yes
they said are you aware that it's been
used
as a drop for
criminals
to get rid of their drugs or you know
it's a drug drop i believe that's the
yes the phrase
and um i said well of course i didn't
know what do you mean and they said well
people have rented it they were a gang a
gang
from uh liverpool
and um
they took my house
and they dropped the drugs in the bay or
they and there was a helicopter that
came on the roof it's a flat roof and
they they had cocaine they had 30
something like 13 million
pounds worth of work no no it wasn't
like a little thing this was a map
13 million jesus
wholesale
well of course i was horrified because i
didn't know i mean i don't have anything
to do with the people that rent it don't
just take the money you know yeah
and i was i well i could get more for it
because it's really lovely
was when it was reported of course in
the daily mail
um
all the people online
said oh she must be in it you know she's
part of the gadget
they were calling me miriam escobar
but actually talking about starting out
amelia obviously your mother loves you
because you're her daughter yeah but she
is actually a sort of a fan as well you
know it's not it's not quite that it's
um
she is oh goodness right so
my uh uh
one day my mum came to set on the star
wars set uh and i was getting this thing
called cyber scand which is where you
stand in this kind of
loads of cameras and they kind of take
your form and put you into a computer
and make a toy or a
some sort of
merchandise or your face on a cushion
um and so
i go off and do this and i come back and
mum's like i've made a great friend and
i'm like brilliant it's lovely excellent
and she's like the merchandise you know
director of all of star wars or
something i'm like wow
very impressive
and then before i know it what comes in
the post um is loads of cushions
my face on it so
my own mum i guess she gets to see it a
fair amount you know but apparently it's
not enough so
i'm just kind of blown away how much
merchandise there is yes it's great and
it was like the pre-merchandise not even
the real stuff is out yet and my mom has
all of it and doesn't know about the
doll yet so we'll show you this is so
weird i don't know is this in your flat
or her house
right okay so basically she'll be really
funny if i came home and it was
everywhere in my opinion
okay so this is this is this is amelia's
actual bedroom
[Laughter]
this is like a joke and then and then
oh
and then oh my goodness we found the
photo but it's not like that now
there is another reason why i'm saying
your first date back to that
yeah
come on in
this little thing once
i don't have a cv i just have a bedroom
but this is cool though so your mother a
big fan but brad pitt also a perfect fan
that was the best night of my life yes
tell the story quickly
[Applause]
yeah there's a duvet
slippers uh no yeah there was this
auction thing that happened and um i
don't they called me and said would you
you know do you want to do you want to
um auction something off like maybe sort
of an experience watching the show with
you or something and i was like okay
it's lovely it's great for charity yeah
it'll be for some you know some
something yeah and it'll be fine anyway
so i get there and it's amazing it'll be
a good thing
um i get there and it's basically like
this it's basically it's the oscars
there's so many celebrities in this room
and i suddenly remember that i said that
i would auction something off and so the
fear grows
so i was petrified absolutely petrified
and then um the person whose table i was
on is a friend and he was being very
kind and kind of put the paddle up and i
was like thanks very much that's very
sweet that'll be that uh and then
someone else's paddle up went up across
the other side of the room and i didn't
really know and then suddenly it was
sort of becoming a bit of money and i
was kind of thinking oh this is
absolutely mental and someone went it's
brad pitt and i was like lol
yeah exactly
and i look over to the room and he's got
his paddle up brad's paddle that has
brown
experience
no
not quite well it didn't work out
because the person whose friend was my
friend i think was probably all set up
personally who was my friend ended up
you know doing the highest bid but um
but uh yeah i just kind of looked over
with just the most insane emoji heart
eyes being like this is just the
greatest moment of my life my mum's not
watching
um there was a slight road rage incident
and um you know those crossings whether
absolutely i don't know if it's the same
rules apply but um
they're not staggered they're straight
cross road thing
i mean you're turning no idea what
you're talking about keep going so you
turn right you have to turn in front of
each other not behind each other on a
staggered crossing you know what i mean
no it's anyone now coming in
so so no basically
okay and you've got to go behind each no
you want to go in the front i had to go
in front because it was a it was in
front
so this woman was coming towards me and
wanting to go right her right and i was
going right so i i turned to go in front
of her and she went
and as if i had tried to drive into her
and i thought okay well there's no one
else coming so i'll just to keep her
happy i'll do what's wrong but i'll go
behind her and she was
doing that in the in the car
and it was starting to really piss me
off because i was right and i was
helping her out
and then i suddenly got this red mist
just as our cars were coming next to
each other i suddenly went [__] yeah
just as she was doing that she went
[Laughter]
this is based on your life i mean this
is things yeah
loosely graham no but things like isn't
the washing machine that happened to you
what the the washing
you were very hungover oh
yeah
tell jodie foster that story
all their stories are really cool though
grail
when i was teaching
this is what this show is based on
i went home one weekend and i was in my
30s i was probably 33 years of age i
went home to see my
mother
and then i went back and while i was at
home my mother did my washing for me
because i was only 33.
then i went back on the
on the sunday night i got really drunk
uh and then i went for a curry
and then the next day i went into school
i'm gonna i went into school and it was
a school in slough and it was quite a
rough school but they had a really
brilliant hearing impaired department so
there were hearing impaired kids who
uh you know struggled they were
they were really looked after in school
anyway i was really hungover i went
there and about break time i felt really
uncomfortable i thought something's not
right you know
so i went to the toilet
and i pulled my trousers down and
some of my mother's knickers had got
i got mixed up in the washington
and i was wearing my mother's hand
and i went oh god no oh i remember going
oh you loser this is
such a low point you [__] loser
and then
the curry and the booze the curry and
the booze kicked in from the night
before
so i
i did like a fecal jackson pollock
and i started
i started going oh god not this not this
as well oh jesus so i cleaned myself up
and i pulled my mother's pants back
and i went back into the um
classroom and i saw one of the hearing
impaired kids just looking at me like
this
and that's when i remembered that my i
had a microphone directly
[Applause]
so maybe mundone isn't that far-fetched
[Music]
you